Hello, everybody from the floor...
Actually, wait, let me put my phone... I'm reading chat from my phone.
You can barely hear me, I don't know.
Wait.
Is it louder?
Is it better?
It's quiet.
Slightly.
What if I put it here?
Is that better?
And I don't know if I was before.
Is it okay?
I can't have floor time.
Do I need to... turn it up, maybe?
Hold on, let me get up.
Eww.
I can't see my computer, so I don't know if it's...
I don't know if it's... if it's... if it's... good.
Oh, it's good now.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to me.
I'm on the floor.
And you might be wondering why... what's happening.
It's because...
Take it easy.
Thank you, Mimi.
It's because... I... I got... I was all dizzy, shaky... earlier.
Uh... and so I've just been laying on the floor for like...
Um...
Like...
Maybe, like, the past...
Two hours.
I've just been on the floor.
I'm feeling a bit better now.
Luckily.
I...
Had some... fruit.
Yummy!
Oh, she sounds so...
Small and pathetic.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Yeah.
But I'm feeling a bit better.
I just thought I would be...
Still pretty low energy...
For...
The game.
If I did a normal stream.
But I did not want to stream.
So here I am on the floor.
And I would encourage you to also join me...
On the floor.
You know...
You ever just lay on the floor.
Oh my gosh.
Game control.
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you.
I say ASMR.
It's only because...
I'm just gonna be chillin'.
It's...
It's not like a...
It's not...
There's no excitement here.
I'm on the floor.
The floor is comfy.
Extract my electrolytes.
Oh, I have been drinking.
Many electrolytes I have.
Don't worry.
I don't know.
Usually once I...
Once I eat...
I feel better.
But I...
It took a really long time.
It took like...
A really long...
Like two hours after I ate.
For me to...
Start feeling.
Actually...
It really wasn't until the fruit.
Yeah.
You gotta mop before you lay on the floor.
Luckily...
You know...
I keep my floor...
Well...
The maid cafe...
It's a little dusty.
Roses are red.
It's hot today.
Make me in those pain.
Go away.
The best way to cure any illness is laying on...
Nice cold bathroom floor.
That's so true.
One of those standing desks that descends all the way to the floor.
That's a good idea.
Give a minute.
Thank you.
I'm okay.
Thank you guys.
I really appreciate it.
I'm okay.
I just...
I didn't...
I still...
I still wanted to talk to you guys.
It's not so much to ask.
And so I decided I'll lay on the floor and do it.
Do the cats visit you on the floor?
Nobody has visited me yet, unfortunately.
Can we join you on the floor?
Yes!
I encourage...
I encourage floor activity.
Parafloral activity.
How do you thank you so much for the vibe gifted?
That was pretty good.
You have to...
You have to admit.
Sagrada Familia Cathedral in Barcelona.
And the English audio guide sound exactly like...
Donna Burke.
It might be her.
It might be.
Even though she melts on the floor, she thinks of us.
Yeah.
I'm thinking of you.
On the floor.
What of it?
Hmm?
Laying on the floor, too.
Nice.
Parafloral.
Can we get much higher?
Parasocial?
No, I'm paranormal.
I'm paranormal.
Supernatural.
I was not familiar with your cake game.
Oh!
Oh, yeah.
It's like the one thing I do have.
Is my fat booty.
Oh, my gosh.
I could go for...
Do you guys know that snack?
Pirate's booty?
I could go for that right now.
That sounds pretty yummy.
Do you guys know it?
It's like...
White...
Cheddar...
Is it cheddar?
White...
It's like a cheese.
But...
Like a white cheese.
It's like Cheetos.
Hi, paranormal.
I'm abby-normal.
Never heard of it till now?
Oh, my gosh.
I recommend.
It's like more of a subtle flavor.
And it doesn't make you feel like you're eating...
You know...
Radioactive...
Like...
Cheetos.
I'm at work so I can't join the floor gang.
Well, you could...
Re-listen to this and be on the floor with me.
When you get home.
I'm readjusting.
Sorry.
Is it crunchy?
Yeah, it's crunchy.
Yeah.
Work on the floor.
Mm-hmm.
Laying in Beth.
In Beth.
Laying in my Beth.
I'm laying in my Beth.
No, I'm laying on the floor.
Freaky ghost Beth.
Now...
This is a good time to go to sleep, maybe.
Unless it's morning for you.
I don't know.
I could go back to sleep.
Second sleep.
What's my favorite jelly?
I'm at the Japanese Mart looking at the shelf.
I don't think they...
What is it?
In Japan?
I don't think they sell it in the States, unfortunately.
But it's...
The...
What's it called?
Manmaru?
Minmaru?
Manmaru Life.
Grape Cognac Jelly.
It's my favorite one.
Aye!
My Nan Life.
Sasuga Murphy.
How do you remember?
My Nan Life.
What are my symptoms?
I feel silly.
I feel a little silly.
But yeah, Grape Cognac Jelly is my favorite.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
That's contagious.
Yes.
Uh oh.
You're gonna catch the silly.
It's terminal.
How do you think I died?
Shady and Octus, thank you.
Folding clothes...
Laying on the floor.
Folding clothes.
I hate folding clothes.
Yeah, me too.
You two return my new name.
What is your new name?
What is that?
Died of Silly.
Sorry if it's quiet, that's probably me.
Cause I'm not talking very loud, I'm on the floor.
Great minto of the floor, what is your wisdom?
I think everybody should lay on the floor for a couple of minutes a day.
Yeah.
Silly's got a hold of us all now.
Yeah, you can get a doctor's note for that.
You can say like, hey.
Hey.
Can't come in.
I caught the Silly.
Hey.
Everybody would just think you're...
Being...
Very...
Being so...
Kind.
Thoughtful that you're...
Looking out for everybody else's well-being.
Are you a tea drinker whilst ill?
I'm a tea drinker 24, 7, 365 days a year.
There isn't a moment I'm not drinking tea.
My gamer sups with your code came in the mail today.
What'd you get?
Assembling a wardrobe that took...
Oh my god.
I just heard the stream labs.
Mateo, thank you!
Floor gang.
I heard Spongebob come...
I don't have my headphones in.
I don't...
You guys probably couldn't hear it.
Wait, I'm scared to drink tea?
Kidney stone.
What?
Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh, donos are muted?
Oh, that's okay.
I can hear it.
Wait.
Kid...
What do you mean kidney stones?
From...
From tea.
Huh?
I guess if you're dehydrated.
Oh.
Sugar tea will give you kidney stones.
If you have kidney stones, go to Disney World.
Go ride Big Thunder Mountain.
Sit on the seat very last of the roller coaster.
And it will...
It will dislodge.
This is a real thing.
It's real.
I learned it from TikTok.
But...
But actually, apparently, that is a real thing that some people do.
Is they...
They go to...
Thundermount in a Disney World and...
Or Disneyland.
I don't actually know which one it is.
And then they...
Uh...
It will help the kidney...
Kidney stone...
Dislodge.
The Florida one specifically.
Really?
I don't know.
Actually, how do you...
How do you get rid of a kidney stone usually?
Jeffrey, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Sorry, I missed it.
Dr. Minky is not a medical doctor.
Yes, I am.
American healthcare movie.
Hehehehe.
I don't know though.
Prices to Disney are so expensive.
You'll probably...
Spend so much there.
As much as a doctor, right?
Logan, also thank you so much for the 10 gifted...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Getting on every ride at Disney and going...
Is this the kidney stone removal ride?
Yeah!
Oh, there's this thing at Disney.
It's called...
Pixie dusting.
Like...
And it's when...
It's when, like...
I guess a staff member does something kind to you.
Like, uh...
Maybe they'll let you have a fast pass for free.
Or...
They'll let you...
Meet a certain, like, character or something.
So people will be like...
Oh my god, I went to Disney and...
I got pixie dusted.
Oh my gosh, it was so...
It was like a dream.
It's supposed to be like a magical moment, you know?
But you could go...
And you could say...
Oh my god, I got pixie dusted.
My kidney stone...
Dis...
Thank you, Walt!
What
a...
What a magical moment!
Kidney dusted.
How magical!
Thank you!
Thank you, Walt!
Thank you so much!
Does Disney World accept most health insurance for the ride?
Maybe.
Probably.
Disneyland traumatized me.
Uh-oh.
Nine, did you go on...
Mr. Toad's wild ride?
Do you guys know that ride?
Okay.
I've never seen the movie.
I've never seen the movie, but...
It's about a guy, Mr. Toad.
And...
He...
Um...
Gets into some crazy antics, and then he gets sentenced to jail.
No, sorry, not jail.
Death penalty.
No.
Maybe jail.
I don't remember.
But he breaks out of the prison, and he gets hit by a train, and then he goes to hell.
And that's the end of the ride.
If it was painless, then it was actually magical.
I probably would be more painless, because you're riding the coaster, you don't even notice it, probably.
I'm not a doctor.
Have you seen all the custom voice-back request messages?
Uh...
He has sent them to me.
I have not had a chance to start on them yet.
I was going to start tomorrow.
Mm-hmm.
Does Mr. Toad help with kidney stones?
No.
The adrenaline suppresses the pain.
Probably.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get a lot of...
I'm on TikTok.
I get a lot of theme park TikToks.
I get a lot...
Oh my gosh.
You guys.
The new epic universe has opened.
The park...
It's an extension of Universal in Florida.
And...
All I'm getting though...
I was excited to see the rides.
The roller coasters especially.
There's a one...
It's like a dueling star racer.
I can't remember if that's the name.
But...
Mm-mm.
Death...
Death of Rock.
A.K.A.
Koban.
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much.
Happy, happy birthday!
The original idea of Disneyland was that you were the main character in the movie when you ride.
So actually you die and go to hell with Mr. Toad.
Oh...
That makes more sense.
Sorry your body has betrayed you again, Minto.
Also having a stone dislodge isn't necessarily a blessing.
That's when the real pain begins.
I don't want to think about it.
I'm sorry.
But...
Epic Universe.
I was excited to see all the roller coasters.
And instead, I keep getting thirst traps.
I keep seeing the invisible man.
And he is literally lusting over every lady.
This man has so much charisma.
I...
And I can't...
I can't stop seeing all the girlies fawning over this guy.
Just being like...
It's the invisible man.
And he like...
He'll like come up and he'll like take the back of his hand and like stroke the person's face.
You know?
Stuff like that.
What?
Listening while drowning.
Don't drown.
No.
Kidney stones get peed out.
Or the roller coaster.
Yeah.
Procedure or roller coaster.
Those are your only options.
Not very invisible if you keep seeing him.
The only invisible man I know is Duran Duran.
Is not bad.
You can't always leave...
Yeah, 100% from the Metal Gear Solid 5 soundtrack.
Yes.
Encore!
That's exactly as I remembered.
Why aren't you feeling well?
My Bukos levels are low, I think.
I'm a little... I'm a little woozy.
I kinda wanna go to the Godzilla rides...
Say, in the amusement park.
It is a combat orchestra.
It is a combat orchestra?
What is that, touring?
Boob levels down.
Never.
You can eat.
I did eat.
I did.
That's why I was so like, I'll be fine.
And then, I was not fine.
Did you ever heard of you took a kid?
It was the James Bond theme Durandera.
Wait.
The only...
Okay, I'm gonna be honest.
The only James Bond theme that I remember is...
I'll die.
Another day.
Guess I'll die.
Marco, thank you.
My gamer subs merch got delivered today.
The cup is super cute.
Can't wait to use the mousepad as a playmat next time I play magic.
Thank you.
Thanks for ordering.
Mint on the floor.
I hope you're well and you feel more minky soon.
Next stream, I will 100% be okay.
But, I will probably have to push...
Load Runner to next week.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
It's funny.
I didn't even notice that I was doing multiple Runner games in a row.
Blade Runner.
Load Runner.
That's it.
Mint is stinky.
Maybe...
Booty Runner.
Dang.
Hold on.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna move.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, I can't reach out if I look this way.
Okay, hold on.
I'm moving you guys too.
Mint of the floor.
What is your wisdom?
Um...
More wisdom?
Temple Runner next.
Temple Run.
Cookie Run.
Give me all your running games.
I'm now a...
I'm a run tuber.
We're running.
Can you watch my dog?
I can't even watch chat.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Load Runner was from 1994.
I think we'll be okay to wait one more week.
Are you sure?
Oh, wait.
Let me...
Let me take off this.
It might help with the sound.
Is that better?
I realize I'm probably a little...
Oh?
What am I hearing?
Am I hearing myself?
Oh?
Maybe?
It's about the same.
Can't tell.
Echo?
Echo Echo.
Oh?
I hate anime.
And don't like VTubers.
Wait...
But you are my exception because...
Both because of my love for Metal Gear.
Yeah.
Watching you slowly descend to and continue across two lifetimes.
Also, what the hell is an...
Oshii.
Oshii just means...
Like...
Okay, so...
Thank you!
Thank you, pirate.
Runner game.
Uma Musume Pretty Derby running game, yeah.
Oshii means like...
Push.
For everybody.
Actually wondering.
My dog's name is Maggie.
So it's like a...
You know...
You're right, grass, but it's also a different kanji.
Different kanji.
But it means like the person...
It's your favorite member because you're wanting to push them to...
The top.
Poop.
Poop to the top.
Ghostrunner 1 and 2.
I got my gamer subs recently and the design is certainly interesting.
Interesting.
What do you mean?
Push, push.
Me, when I push, push my Ushi's butt to the top.
Yeah, it's like the one time I give you permission.
You may push.
Yeah, yeah, that's the kanji.
Right there.
Yay!
Heave ho!
Why?
It's not that heavy, I think.
I don't know.
What are you going to do with all that junk?
All that junk inside that junk?
I'm going to get you to the top.
Get my Ushi up, up, up.
That's my Ushi's humps.
My Ushi's lady lumps.
Check them out.
Because she is my Ushi, I want you... Wait, what was I saying?
Oh, no.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Let's go.
Sorry if my karaoke song request yesterday was rude.
No, no.
I think... I think Matthew more so is like... What's the word?
It wasn't rude.
It's just...
And this, I think, goes for, like, a lot of streamers.
Like, I feel really bad if I'm in a collab with people and someone says it's their birthday and it's kind of hard for me to, you know, either see it or wish them a happy birthday in the moment.
Um... I think if you're ever requesting something like that, it would be better for, like, this kind of stream.
Like, a talking stream or, um...
You know, even karaoke.
So that... When I do karaoke streams, if someone requests a song and I'm...
I will usually write it down when I have the moment, you know?
But at the time, I didn't have the moment, you know?
So I think that... Oh, sorry.
I almost just dropped my phone.
I think that goes for...
For...
Pretty much any streamer, you know?
Mm.
Yeah, yeah.
But don't worry.
You're all good.
It's hard to remember sometimes, you know?
When you're watching and you just kind of want to...
I feel the most bad, especially because it's like...
If someone sends it as a super chat, like, I feel bad because...
Like, example, again, like a birthday.
If I do it during a collab, it's...
I feel... I feel more bad, you know?
Nah.
Yeah.
That's it.
My Oshi brings all the wisps to the yard, and they're like...
Oh.
My Oshi's got bars.
That's my Kami Oshidi, y'all.
Y'all.
Don't drop me.
I can't afford to lose brain cells.
She do got bars.
Any VTubers you'd like to collab with.
I...
Would love to collab more with Henya.
Yeah.
I'd like to collab more with Henya.
I like her.
She's my VTuber Kami Oshi.
Collab with JPEG dog.
Oh yeah, he's the best VTuber.
Fun fact, you're bald underneath all your hair.
If only you knew.
Bouncing her DMs, Dayo.
I'm shy.
Usually I'm not good with...
Going to people.
Just help push...
You're on your way, boss.
Manto, could you...
Could you do your best, Dayo?
I'm always doing my best, Dayo.
Oh, wait.
I thought you meant like...
Wait.
I thought you meant like, do your best, Dayo.
Instead of like, do your best, Dayo.
Uh...
Dayo.
Yeah.
I'm listening while donating plasma.
I can't donate plasma.
Because they don't...
Accept ectoplasma.
I guess I could for ghosts.
But I'm so scared of needles.
I pass out.
I took my minto plushie to see Ado yesterday.
And the guy next to me recognized you.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Skiblippers, Dayo.
Wait, that's crazy.
Did you guys become friends?
Did you guys kiss?
What if we kiss during Usewa?
Mwase, mwase, mwasewa.
Mwase, mwase, mwase, mwase.
Mwase, mwase, mwase.
I got the timing for you.
Just follow along, okay?
Mwase, mwase, mwase.
That's even better.
Okay, that's for people that don't want to...
That don't want to kiss a lot.
But then you can say...
Mwase, mwase, mwase.
There's two different versions.
They're both...
They're both good.
They're both valid.
Mwase, mwase.
That was so funny.
Wink, winky.
Got my Minto G-sharp's cup today.
Thank you.
Thank you, Artemis, for ordering.
And thank you.
Thank you.
Romance option.
You have to get a higher social link for romance at the auto concert, I guess.
Are wisps required to kiss when we meet in the wild?
I just think it's a little exciting, though.
When you get so excited.
When you're just like, oh my gosh.
You're a wisp.
I'm a wisp.
You know?
Any updates on the second wave of plushies?
They should be shipping out now.
I've seen people starting to get them.
If you are curious, if you are not sure, you can email MossoBox.
Yes, yes.
I unfortunately do not handle any of the shipping, so I cannot help you.
Does your cafe serve miso soup?
Could you cook me miso soup every morning?
Hey.
Hey now.
I know what that is.
Do you guys know what that is?
If someone asks you, could you make...
Or, oh no.
They say, I...
Uh, wait.
They ask you...
Wait.
They say, can you serve me...
No.
No, no.
They say, I want...
They say, I want to eat your miso soup every day.
And that is, apparently, a marriage proposal.
Keep trying, queen.
It's as, like...
It's up there with...
It's up there.
Marriage.
When you...
When...
I couldn't remember if it was, like...
Ask...
You to...
Uh...
Make it?
Or, if I...
If they say, I want to eat it.
I don't remember.
I don't know.
I guess it's the same thing, though.
Old-timey Japanese proposal.
Taking notes for my next minto meat ingredient.
I have miso soup.
It's called...
I can get it from the sewer.
Kissing causes pregnancy.
Don't do it.
The real question is, do you accept it?
Uh...
Oh...
Well, you know, I'm a cafe.
I'm a cafe, so, like...
You...
You would pay me to make it every morning.
You know?
I'm a mid-cafe, yeah.
So...
If you...
Pay the...
The price of the soup?
Yeah, I'll make it every morning.
You just come in.
That's illegal.
What do you mean?
This is an establishment.
Is this the Krusty Krab?
The soup toe.
How much?
I don't know.
How much is, like, a bowl of miso?
100 yen?
200 yen?
Fancy miso.
300 yen.
10 dollars?
Holy moly.
What am I putting in there?
Gold?
Complimentary.
At least 350.
I'm gonna put...
What do you want in it?
I like my miso soup with spranch.
I like some spranch in there.
Soup is legal.
They can't take that away from us.
For now.
I hope you feel better soon.
Thank you, Ellie.
Thank you so much.
Spranch.
Miso corn soup?
Does that even exist?
Would it taste any good?
Probably not.
Probably would be bad.
How long have I been streaming?
Okay.
Is it illegal to say gyoza?
Yes.
Now you're going downtown.
Wait, I said gyoza too.
I said it again.
I'm going downtown.
Okay.
I arrest you.
You arrest me.
Okay?
Okay.
Wait.
I arrest you first.
Alright.
Turn around.
Handcuffs.
Ka-chang!
Alright.
Now I turn around.
Handcuff me.
I would like to order a Krabby Patty with Diet Kelp.
Who was driving?
Uh...
Mmm...
If I'm here, and you're there, then who was fun?
Where we could share handcuffs?
What are you trying to say?
That you have itty bitty tiny wrists?
Oh my god.
My wrists are so small.
I could like share handcuffs with you.
Because my wrists are so skinny.
Oh my god.
I have like the tiniest wrists ever.
Sharing handcuffs.
Scandalous.
Play Umamu.
I mean Ace Combat.
Good night!
That wasn't what he meant.
Oh, what do you mean?
Wait.
Now I don't know.
Everybody, time to do your...
Floor stretches.
Oh my...
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Big stretch.
I wonder if I could eat this mic.
Good stretch.
Sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Bite the mic.
Please no Minto E2 ASMR.
Oh yeah, that's what's supposed to be ASMR.
It's laying on the floor ASMR.
Do you feel it?
Do you feel like I'm...
On the...
Wait.
Hold on.
Let me get up.
I'll make it ASMR.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I realized something.
I know why the mic is so weird.
Give me a second, actually.
Hold on.
Oh.
Test, test, test.
Test, test, test, test, test, test.
Test, test.
I realized...
I realized it was settings for my other mic.
Sorry.
Is it too loud?
How about this?
Is it okay?
It was on the setting for my other mic.
Sorry.
Okay, hold on.
That's why it sounded probably weird.
Um.
Hello.
It sounded really low.
Minto.
I'm in your left ear.
Now it's like I'm really laying on the ground.
And I'm inside your left ear.
Ugh.
Sorry.
My nose is really runny.
I think it's...
I think it's all my ectoplasm...
From my brain...
Going down.
Yeah.
Now I'm haunting your left ear.
On the ground.
The left ear says...
Wait.
The left side of the brain is...
The mathy side.
And the right side is the creative side.
Actually, I don't remember.
Which is which?
I only have my right earphone in.
Uh-oh.
My nose is so stuffy.
Why?
Probably because I'm laying on the floor.
And I'm probably...
Inhaling all my cat...
Hair.
You know.
I just vacuumed.
I think I'm allergic to my cats.
I think...
I think I'm...
Allergic to my cats.
So I...
Uh...
I have stuffy nose.
Naiminto.
Good night.
Thank you.
Worst fear is a pet owner.
I know.
But I don't think it's like...
Super serious.
Wait.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
Do your eyes get itchy?
Sometimes.
If I like...
You know...
Okay.
You only know this if you have a cat.
But sometimes you just want to like...
Just sniff their head.
You know?
I never...
My sister when she had a baby...
She was like...
I just want to sniff their head.
I was like...
What are you talking about?
But I just want to do that to my cat.
Why are you sniffing a human baby?
She's like...
It has baby smell.
But with cat...
Sometimes I don't even go for the head.
Sometimes I go for the back.
And I'm like...
Yeah.
That's the stuff.
There's this...
What is it?
The tox...
Toxoplasmosis.
I don't remember.
I don't know what it is.
But it's like...
Something you get from your cats.
That makes you...
Toxoplasmosis.
It makes it that you are...
Sick in the head for your cat.
I'm sick in the head for my cat.
I'm sick in the head.
Okay.
I'm going to go to the right side now.
Then we'll come.
Ectoplasmosis.
Sick in the head for me, though.
Yeah.
You get ectoplasmosis.
Get ectoplasmosis right now.
Ectoplasmosis.
I'm injecting it into your brain.
Into your bloodstream.
Into your DNA.
Ectoplasmosis.
For generations and generations and generations.
Sick in the head.
True.
And real.
True and real.
Fox.
Ecto.
Ecto die.
I can't keep getting up, you guys.
I got up this last time and...
I got...
I got really dizzy.
So...
I'm stuck on the ground.
Yeah, we're on the floor still.
Is this how wisps are made?
Yeah, probably.
Hmm.
I might be sleeping here.
Right side minto.
What's your opinion on left side minto?
Left side minto is a bitch.
She can't even open a pickle jar.
But me, I got all the muscle.
I'm brains and prime.
She's a little weenie.
Don't trust left side minto.
She's a weenie.
Do you have water and snacks on the floor?
I do have...
Oh my gosh.
I have some liquid IV.
That stuff is ass.
Liquid IV tastes so bad.
I hate it.
It's so gross.
It's...
It's like the worst flavor ever.
The flavor of peach.
I have peach flavor and you'd think it would be good.
But it's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Most...
Just most flavors suck.
What do you guys recommend?
What do you recommend for the...
For...
For liquid IV.
It's supposed to rehydrate, not taste good.
They could do both.
Real gang wars.
Right side minto versus left side minky.
Minky.
Lemon lime.
I don't think you could go wrong with that.
Pedialyte.
Oh yeah.
Blackberry peach.
It also has caffeine.
Wait.
Do all liquid IV have caffeine?
Uh-oh.
I've heard...
I've heard good things about the Pedialyte.
But I always thought it was for babies.
Because of the name.
Did you ever get that minto drink from Off-Kai?
No.
But I was told that it had like crazy levels of alcohol in it.
I would probably...
I would be...
I think I would still be drunk if I...
If I...
If I drank it...
I would be drunk to this very day.
There's a Pedialyte for adults.
Wait.
Is it...
So it is for babies.
Coconut milk or Pedialyte.
Both are good.
Coconut milk?
Yummy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Made of the floor.
What is your wisdom?
Don't drink liquid IV.
It tastes like...
Butt.
It's so bad.
I don't know why it's so bad.
I don't know.
It's more for kids than babies.
Okay.
I was...
I...
I will...
I have some power...
Powerade too.
But I was like...
Oh, well I have this liquid IV.
I know it's so bad.
But I should just get through it.
I can't do it.
Bro, I can't do it.
It's so bad.
Bro, I can't...
I can't drink the liquid IV.
It's so...
Damn, bro.
Bro.
Bro, I can't...
I'm too weak for liquid IV.
No.
How do you put it in my...
I even put it in the...
In the giant Gamersupps bottles.
I do it with that.
So it's a lot of water.
And still...
Still...
Have you tried Pocari Sweat?
Yeah.
I like Pocari.
I like Pocari Sweat.
I like Aquarius.
They don't sell Aquarius in the States though, do they?
But I do like Pocari.
Mmm, yeah, yeah.
Those are tasty, yeah.
And you can get Pocari...
Like, mixture too.
I think.
Ah.
Don't know so you can buy a better drink.
I just didn't wanna...
I'm not...
I don't wanna be wasteful.
I bought the liquid IV.
The liquid ID.
Brother.
I became liquid.
I stole his social security number.
Actually, that guy probably doesn't have a social security number.
But, um...
I don't wanna wait.
I bought it.
The liquid IV.
I only have, I think, one more packet of it.
So I just gotta...
I just gotta do it.
Maybe I'll give it to some sap.
Maybe I'll give it to some sucker.
I'll be like, yeah.
Try this liquid IV.
Oh, it's really good.
Drink taxes paid.
Thank you.
Nice.
We'll try it.
Yeah.
Send it to Matara.
I'll send it to Mataracon.
Here, Matara.
This will make you feel really hydrated and good.
Slightly used liquid IV.
That's diabolical.
You guys are evil.
You guys are...
You guys are so evil.
I'm gonna get arrested for shipping powder and through the mail.
They're gonna be like, what is this, anthrax?
Oh, liquid IV.
That's worse.
FBI.
I'm gonna get swatted.
Help you feel better soon.
Thank you.
Suckers born every minute.
True.
Even when dying on the floor.
I mean, they're so cute.
Really?
Thanks.
I'm like... I'm serious.
I look exactly like my thumbnail right now.
That's exactly how I'm laying.
Just like my thumbnail.
Oh, yeah.
Cake and all.
You know it, baby.
You hear that?
Did you hear that?
Booty up.
If your allergies are kicking in, it can be the swelling of your inner ear and make you dizzy.
I... Oh my gosh.
I can't have the antihistamines because it makes me pass out.
But I will take some tonight.
That's a good idea.
Thank you.
Good.
Good idea, Jester.
Thank you.
Okay, you want more... more drum power?
Wait, what should I... what should I play?
This is karaoke now.
What song should I play?
Oh wait, I know.
Well...
Oh wait, how's it going?
Oh.
Nothing will ever take me away from you.
This is kind of a workout.
I'll bless the rains down in Africa.
Okay, now you have to change the thumbnail to make them red.
Rickroll us next, please.
Oh.
We're no strangers to love.
You know no rules, and so do I.
This is definitely the beat.
That's definitely...
That's definitely the beat of...
That we're gonna give...
That's exactly what the drum man's doing.
He's just going...
On the drums.
No.
Sage, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you!
I'mma play umo musume.
Have fun!
I'll take cake every morning instead of soup.
Hold on, I'm gonna move a bit again.
Hold on, sorry.
Wait...
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I think it might be time for me to...
To...
To leave.
I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I'm glad that we could have this talk.
On the floor.
And...
You guys...
Sorry I've been in your right ear for a while.
Sorry.
This was a good chat.
You know.
You guys take care.
Um...
Roll on the floor a little bit if you want.
And...
I'll see you guys when I see you next!
Okay!
Au tu minto!
Thank you guys.
I have to get up though.
I have to get up!
I don't want to get up.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Thank you everybody.
Oh...
Every time I get up...
The world...
Goes black.
Hold on.
Oh...
I am so sorry you guys.
I really didn't expect to feel this bad today.
I didn't expect to feel this bad today.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm okay though.
I had a lot of fun.
Thanks you guys.
For making me...
Feel better.
Okay.
See you later.
Floor minto!
Out!
That's me digging back into the dirt.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Okay?